[Musique]
quelle est la seule espèce de cervidés
dont les mâles et les femelles portent
des bois les caribous qu'on appelle en
europe les rênes chez la quasi totalité
des cervidés ce sont les mâles qui
arbore cet organe aussi caduc mais chez
une seule espèce la femelle aussi et
coiffés d'un panache si en amérique du
nord le rennes est toujours demeurer
sauvage en eurasie les rênes ont été en
partie domestiquées dès le 5ème siècle
le nombreux peuple semi-nomade les
utilisent encore aujourd'hui pour tirer
de lourdes charges leur viande leur
fourrure et le lait des femelles ont
aussi assuré la survie des humains dans
ces contrées nordiques
les rails sont associés aux festivités
de noël et d'hiver en particulier en
scandinavie et dans toute l'europe de
l'est les reines qui ramène les gens à
la maison en toute sécurité
durant les hivers rigoureux serait à
l'origine de l'histoire populaire du
père noël
[Musique]